hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update apparently sony thinks that
a lot of wii owners could appreciate
upgrading to a ps4 playstation boss
Andrew House has said that we owners who
never owned a ps3 or xbox 360 are making
the transition to ps4 he says this could
be because this is a really good
all-around entertainment device for a
family in addition to having great games
sony has previously said that almost
fifty percent of current ps4 owners
never had a ps3 because so many people
are new to the PlayStation House said
that Sony is interested in remastering
back catalog games for the ps4 including
the last of us which is coming out on
July 29 according to house there could
be more remasters on the way he said I
hesitate to say this because I know
committed gamers may roll their eyes
about it but there's an opportunity with
some of the remastering or reimagining
from ps3 franchises that will
potentially find an audience that hasn't
played them in the previous generation
because they skipped that generation
Sony worldwide studios boss Shuhei
Yoshida has said previously that the
Uncharted series is another good
candidate for a ps4 remaster for even
more PlayStation 4 news stay tuned to
gamespot com